let's go next to our caller from the six
seven eight area code who is calling
today from six seven eight hey my name
is Goran hair I'm a conservative but I
like to just brought in my views on
things I'd like to listen to your side
my question to you is I want first say
this is kind of cool that you do this
allow people to call in and ask your
questions because all right this is how
I thought in my view but you know steven
crowder of course he's one of the major
conservatives on the right on youtube
yeah you know when I when I was on the
Joe Rogan program Joe told me that
steven crowder is a comedian yes yes he
does comedian stuff but he also does
this politic stuff and that's what I was
leaning more towards is what like would
you lean out to go have a conversation
with him like on tech center ship or
like health healthcare because I think
that would be wonderful to see I would
be glad to do that if he was interested
in doing something like that sure okay I
was just wondering because I know a lot
of people don't like to necessarily talk
to each other on either side of the lane
and if it's like for you it would be
just something to show it's a good show
of faith yeah it's more just I'm willing
to engage with people's ideas if they
are good faith actors and their approach
is not to be bomb throwers you know I I
hesitate to imagine that steven crowder
is going to want to have that
conversation with me and I know that
he's a comedian and I'm not a comedian
so there may be an incongruence there of
some kind but certainly I would be glad
to have that conversation with him all
right thank you very much have a Merry
Christmas and a Happy New Year
all right Happy Hanukkah thank you so
much one of our sponsors is privacy calm
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy calm slash Pakman
I've been using privacy for a little
over a year now you've heard me talk
about it before it's a life saver and
here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account without the merchant
ever knowing your real information so
this allows you to keep your banking
information secure but also to take
control of your finances you can create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them you can delete them
anytime you want so when you do this it
means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
I love using free trials because I know
I won't be charged when the trial is
over if I use a virtual credit card
number you're keeping your identity
private by not telling companies who you
are you're keeping your bank or credit
card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft and it's
free there's no catch whatsoever but if
you want privacy also offers a $10 a
month plan that gives you one percent
cashback and lets you create 36 credit
cards a month and a $25 a month plan
tailored more for small businesses where
you can create 60 card numbers a month
and much more but definitely go ahead
and at least get started with the free
plan you'll protect your financial info
companies can't charge you unexpectedly
and like I said you'll get five dollars
to spend when you sign up at privacy
calm / Pakman